who
who are you we're from mars don't be
afraid
we have children just like you on mars
human beings have contemplated whether
life exists beyond earth
for thousands of years ancient one of
mars
i call upon you it's thought
that there's a possibility that simple
microbial life might exist within our
solar system
but not advance complex life
doesn't mean it doesn't exist just means
we don't expect to find it
largely because the conditions for life
elsewhere in the solar system
appear to be extremely hostile to such
life
since the early 90s technology has
allowed us to locate planets outside of
our solar system
they're known as exoplanets and planet
hunting telescopes like kepler
and tess have discovered roughly 4 000
of them
and counting so we now understand that
majority of stars will have planets
so planets are ubiquitous and because we
just reach
that sensitivity that is allowing us to
detect those exoplanets
this field is uh evolving very rapidly
and while they're too far away to send a
probe to even the closest exoplanets
a team at nasa's jet propulsion
laboratory has been developing a method
more powerful than any telescope ever
built
it'll be able to give us a close-up look
at planets and other objects
thousands of light years away find
worlds that are similar to earth
and maybe even discover signs of
intelligent life
so that's what the earth people call a
city
how primitive look at all those
buildings above ground
and it will be amazing discovery first
of all to see that we are not alone
or and how life evolved in that system
so it's enormous step in our sort of
philosophical understanding who we are
and where we go
powerful telescopes like the hubble
space telescope spitzer
herschel and keck observatory have
photographed objects very far away
this galaxy called the sombrero galaxy
is 28 million light years from earth
but even though known exoplanets are as
close as four light years
these are the best images we have all we
really get are just these tiny little
blobs
they just look like fuzzy little points
of light orbiting
some distance from the star so we don't
really see anything that
looks like a planet in fact if we didn't
know any better we might think that it
was just a very very faint star
when in fact it's a very very large
planet reflecting
the star light off of it and of the 4
000 discovered exoplanets
only about 50 of them have been imaged
so basically it's really really hard to
image an exoplanet it's really hard
but not impossible and and that's why
we're aiming to do that you know that's
why we're trying to make that happen but
you're right it's very difficult it's it
certainly is not beyond our
capabilities or won't be beyond our
capabilities
the majority of exoplanets are found
using the transit method
a tiny dip in a star's brightness when a
planet passes
or transits in front of it and it's that
telltale drop-off in light especially
when it repeats over several cycles that
tells us that this is caused by a planet
orbiting the star making regular
transits across its surface
another common method is looking at
slight shifts in a motion of a star when
there's a planet orbiting it
this is known as the radial velocity or
wobble method
planet exerts gravity on the star so
what happens is that
as the planet comes around the star the
star also kind of comes around
the system's center of mass and so the
star has to move
although both of these methods allow
planetary scientists to make predictions
like the basic mass size whether it's
rocky or gaseous
and distance to its host star it doesn't
allow us to see it
in the best case scenario the light can
be analyzed with modern telescopes to
give hints as to whether the planet is
habitable
how can we even tell that a planet is
habitable just by a fuzzy blob
we certainly cannot so the goal with
these telescopes is not to actually
show us what the planet looks like but
it would allow us to analyze the light
coming from the planet the spectrum of
light coming from the planet can be
analyzed
to reveal the chemical components of its
atmosphere a much easier feat than
getting a real-life image
that's because in comparison to a galaxy
exoplanets are
dark and tiny planets just reflect light
from their host star
so even though a planet
may only be uh a few dozen light years
down the road
our chances of seeing it are much
less than seeing a bright star
that's even farther or a bright
galaxy that's billions of light years
away
it's just the nature of the luminosities
involved
even with the upcoming james webb space
telescope which will be the most
powerful space telescope ever built
the images won't give you much more than
fuzzy blobs
what we want is an image where you can
see color variations that distinguish
oceans
continents vegetation and even see
lights at night
that can determine not just if it's
habitable but show proof of advanced
life
but to image an earth-sized exoplanet
that's a hundred light years away
at a decent quality a thousand by a
thousand pixels
you would need a telescope that is
ninety thousand kilometers in diameter
seven times larger than earth and even
if it were made of a super lightweight
material
it would still weigh about a trillion
kilograms
in other words it's not possible
what we need to do instead is rather
than think about even building a
telescope
we need to think about using
nature itself as a kind of telescope and
luckily nature gives us a way to do that
this was discovered by albert einstein
and it's the idea that
mass or gravity can bend the path of
light
as long as that can happen then we can
in theory
go to where all those light rays that
are being bent by a mass
converges and we can take an image this
is called
gravitational lensing
as long as we can choose the right place
to put a telescope
we could in principle look back toward
the sun
image the gravitational lens from a
distant
exoplanet and for the first time we
would actually be able to see
continents we'd be able to see the
oceans and map the coastlines
of a earth-sized planet
maybe 100 light years away this is a
very different approach
to making images with a
telescope that we could build here on
earth but it may in fact be the only way
that we'd be able to directly image
the surface of another planet it may
sound like science fiction
but we've actually observed this
phenomenon before
when light from a distant galaxy is
behind a massive foreground object
from our perspective on earth the mass
of that foreground object bends space
time
creating gravity and bending the light
around that object
this forms a ring called an einstein
ring
to visually demonstrate this you can use
a wine glass to act as the lens or
foreground object
and a light bulb that can act as the
source if we the observer
look through the center of the base of
the wine glass we see a ring of light
and in theory we could use computer
software to decode that ring of light
back into its original state
if you replace the wine glass with the
sun to bend the light and sent a
telescope
now the observer to the point where the
light converges
you could then take images of the ring
and put it back together using software
the sun is massive enough that it will
amplify whatever you're pointing it at
by a factor of a hundred billion just
like an astronomically massive telescope
that's why a team of scientists led by
slavatory chev
at nasa's jet propulsion laboratory are
proposing a solar
gravitational lens mission
flying a small telescope to the solar
gravitational lens will allow us to
study those objects in very fine details
and confirm the presence of life
and study the evolution of life on that
exoplanet
[Music]
there are a few challenges though for
this to work
the telescope will need to be positioned
past the convergence point
at around 650 astronomical units or a u
from the sun
1au equals the distance from the earth
to the sun
neptune is at 30 a.u for example in
voyager 1
the furthest man-made object that was
launched in the 70s
is currently at about 150 au
[Music]
so we have thought about how we can
reach those distances what technology do
we have
and essentially we realize that using
chemical propulsion is very challenging
because the
fastest velocity we were able to achieve
with chemical propulsion
uh was achieved with the new horizons
mission to pluto
and new horizons was able to reach
roughly three astronomical units per
year
with this velocity it will take us a lot
of time to get to solar gravity lens
so we realize that solar
sailing offers a unique alternative with
solar sailing we
are using the solar photons solar light
to gain a very significant momentum that
will push our sail craft
to very high velocity solar sailing has
been successfully demonstrated by the
planetary society
nasa and the japanese aerospace
exploration agency
if done in a way that slava and his team
are proposing
which involves flying close to the sun
the telescope will reach speeds of
roughly 25
au per year so with those velocities we
will be able to reach
solar gravity lens within i would say 20
to
25 years that's the only way to do this
the next challenge is once you get to
650 au
there's no slowing down but this is
where they get a lucky break
it doesn't have just a single focal
point it has a focal line
if you fly a spacecraft towards the
focal region of the slower gravity lens
we don't have to stop
moving along that focal line will still
benefit from that large amplification
another challenge which current
telescopes also face when imaging
exoplanets
is that you have to point the telescope
at a very bright object
in this case the sun this creates a
glare which needs to somehow be blocked
out
in order to see the planet we will use
a very interesting technique called a
coronagraph
so the a star shade at a large
instrument that is
has to be flown in front of our
telescope in space
and that coronagraph will allow us to
block the light from
porn star and suddenly the very faint
light from the exoplanet may
present itself so it's a challenging
technique because
the brightness mismatch fortunately
coronagraphs are being developed and in
use on many planet hunting telescopes
including the upcoming james webb space
telescope
finally the telescope will be limited to
choosing a single target
since changing the angle by just a
degree could mean propelling it billions
of kilometers in the lateral direction
usually people when talking about solar
gravity lens there is a significant
limit
because we currently are limited by
propulsion capability
so we can think that we can fly only
towards one
target essentially and so i'm i think
about solar gravity lens missions like
any planetary exploration
if you fly towards saturn we study in
the whole
a set of satellites uh the whole family
of satellites around saturn with cassini
if you fly around jupiter with galileo
we studied multiple
satellites of jupiter with the solar
gravity lens
flying towards a tropist we can study
every planet in that system
the trapa system is a star with seven
planets orbiting it
three of which are in the theoretical
habitable zone the sweet spot for a
planet to possess liquid water on its
surface and possibly support life
pointing the telescope at the trappist
system could be a solution for looking
at multiple planets
since they orbit the same star
[Music]
another way they're looking to solve
this is to build the telescopes cheaply
and send many of them
these are just a few of the hurdles that
slav and his team face but none of them
are out of reach
and what we realize that most of those
technologies already exist
some of them in a very high technology
readiness level some of them are yet to
reach a very reasonable technology
readiness level but all of them exist in
one form another
most of this technology is being
developed alongside other projects
that need to get far out into
interstellar space cheaply
and in a reasonable amount of time
so ultimately we will transfer those
engineering
developments to allow us to explore
further
more at a very affordable cost solar
gravity lens is our ultimate goal so far
but looking at this we realize that
there are plenty of synergistic efforts
within
the exploration community and we benefit
from them
a benefit from those efforts and we
invite our colleagues and friends to
join
uh in to join us uh to look at those
technologies how we can use those
technologies
in the near term how those technologies
will benefit us in the next 5-10 years
slav and his team receive phase 3
funding from the nasa innovative
advanced concepts program
and are developing methods to
reconstruct the image from an einstein
ring
as well as building instrument
prototypes they hope to launch their
technology demonstration mission in the
next three to five years
so as of now if you could choose one
target
for the solar gravitational lens what
would you choose and why
oh man only one uh
let's take a picture of our closest
neighbor so
the proxima right so proxima b it's our
neighbor
the closer the exoplanet is the larger
its image and therefore the more detail
we will be able to see
the closest star to our solar system
proxima centauri is only
4.2 light years away and it has at least
one but probably
two planets orbiting it i would love to
use the sgl on that to see what
the planetary system next door looks
like
it's possible that once we get a
close-up look at our nearest neighboring
solar system
we'll be able to find out once and for
all whether we're alone
or at the very least get a detailed
image of an exoplanet for the first time
slavin's team hoped to launch their
first mission to image an exoplanet in
the next 12 to 15 years
so it's only in a short 40 years from
today you and i may discuss
the uh images of uh you know
life present on a different exoplanet
and this is how
the uh childhood dream may realize for
many of us
so now we will have a clear
understanding yes we are not alone
and oh by the way our life is excellent
or maybe we just have a confirmation
that those aliens use you know
carbon fuel as stupidly as we do or
maybe they come up with something
excellent and we'll learn from them but
anyway i think it's exciting
opportunity for us to step above our
daily lives and
think about what our universe will tell
us about ourselves
so while we're never going to solve
every problem on earth
we can solve most of them and in
addition to
reducing the pain of life on earth we
can also
increase the excitement of being alive
in the first place
and that's what missions like the solar
gravitational lens
and these next generation of space
telescopes are
allowing us to do and there's something
just
fundamentally essential about learning
about our real
true place in the cosmos and
understanding how it works
you